renault bouchard merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et bienvenue sur la
malle la matinale de rtl france vous
êtes avec nous par téléphone ce matin
alors aujourd'hui on le disait environ
270 millions de personnes dans le monde
au bord de la famine 3 millions
d'enfants meurent chaque année alors la
guerre le changement de climat sont
souvent identifiés comme les premières
causes de ces famines en quoi la
pandémie que traverse le monde risque
d'accentuer davantage aujourd'hui ces
famines oui bonjour en tout cas merci
beaucoup de votre invitation
c'est une question effectivement assez
importante mais monsieur david bentley
dont vous avez rappelé la déclaration il
ya quelques minutes a expliqué que ce
qui était menacée c'est un groupe de 270
millions de personnes qui sont
confrontées par exemple pour l'année
2000 21 a une faim extrême
en réalité pour répondre à votre
question et tout poudret réussir à
sensibiliser un maximum de jambes
d'autorité internationale sur ces deux
fléaux que de dire que l'on connaît dans
le monde entier qui sont tout simplement
en fait les guerres et les manques de
financements jeudi guerre parce que hier
lorsque vous avez contactés pour
préparer cette émission nous avons
évoqué le cas de l'afrique par exemple
on se rend bien compte que les
diffusions d'armement les conflits tout
ce qui en fait agite les 54 pays du
continent africain sont ceux je veux
dire les acteurs principaux qui empêche
tout simplement des gens de vivre qui
les tue et qui viennent gêner par
exemple le travail absolument
extraordinaire je lis ici parce que je
suis très admiratif
le programme alimentaire mondial où vous
avez en fait des milliers de camions ont
des centaines de personnes qui sont dire
au travail tous les jours pour pouvoir
acheminer en fait de la nourriture
voilà alors la chose la plus importante
c'est ce serait en fait en réalité
d'empêcher ce qui se passe est de faire
en sorte que les populations qui sont
toujours les populations innocentes est
depuis victime en fait continue tout
simplement de mourir en silence
renault bouchard
il parlait de david besley donc le
directeur exécutif du programme
alimentaire mondial
il soulignait un paradoxe le 10 décembre
dernier alors qu'il recevait le prix
nobel de la paix à distance
on écoute et on en parle il y a quatre
cent mille milliards de dollars de
richesse dans notre monde aujourd'hui
même au plus fort de la pandémie de co
vide en seulement 90 jours 2700
milliards de dollars supplémentaires de
richesse ont été créés et nous n'avons
besoin que de cinq milliards de dollars
pour sauver de la famine 30 millions de
vies finalement comment est ce que vous
comprenez ce paradoxe est ce qu'on peut
aller à son encontre aujourd'hui il faut
de la volonté politique des dirigeants
les plus riches
oui et je vous prend de vous donner un
exemple le vendredi 20 novembre dernier
la suppression de la république que ce
macron avait reçu à l'elysée les
dirigeants de 14 ans souverain 14h
ionnaires d'actifs et cinq fonds de
capital investissement pour faire un
point par exemple sur les moyens
d'accélérer la transition mondiale vers
une économie neutre en carbone ou les
populations et la planète pourrait il
est y prospérer ensemble est alors au
cours de ce sommet je vais très bref la
suite à une série d'actions concrètes
qui avaient été présentées nouvelle
annonce qui avait été fait et on a fait
intervenir un facteur extrêmement
important avec des poches très profondes
des acteurs et rémy et richissime qui
sont neuf ans souverains qui sont par
exemple franck souverain mubadala d'abou
dhabi devant siggil sénégal
un nouveau front s'ouvre est créé en
inde la bpi france pour la france il ya
un rôle extrêmement important dans le
programme alimentaire mondial le
kazakhstan aussi plus d'autres d'autres
fonds souverains et puis des
gestionnaires d'actifs par exemple comme
morgan stanley pinko ubs et m et puis
des fonds souverains de
capital-investissement veut terminer la
mondiale à la liste la qualité la
suivante que les initiatives qui est une
initiative extrêmement louable a
rassemblé en fait de sauf erreur de ma
part 33 institution financière qui gère
plus de 38 milliards de dollars soit
pour un bon thé lorsque vous êtes de
dire une multiplication par 10 de
grandir par rapport aux membres
fondateurs elle représente entre 30 %
des actifs mondiaux et il est la
suivante lesquelles cet argent pourrait
je le dire sur une part a cité du mâle
réussir à combler en fait les manques
criants en fait le programme alimentaire
mondial a besoin pour mener son action
là c'est à dire il faudrait par exemple
re prévoir un nouveau un nouveau sommet
à nouveau fonds est amené à la
contribution de vous dire de fait de ces
acteurs financiers internationaux merci
allez-y je vous en prie pour conclure
oui et une deuxième chose par exemple j
je pense à l'afrique c'est le rôle très
important qui joué par exemple par
justement si fonds souverains et
notamment par exemple auront de nouveaux
acteurs internationaux comme la chine
par exemple qui a investi un peu partout
sur le continent africain
au point même qu'elle a réussi à gérer
dire à mettre ces pays dans une
difficulté financière est déroulé à
faire un très grand acteur financier
international dont on aimerait qu'ils
puissent lui aussi contribué et aider en
fait à je veux dire l'action de
l'organisme ainsi merci en doute à rené
renault mouchard d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste